[Music]
joining me this week is a podcaster a
commentator a former member of one of
the Marines most elite units and the
host of the athlete titled Jason
Stapleton program Jason Stapleton
welcome to the Rubin report thank you
thank you for having me I could have
worn the same exact thing as you we
could have been in a fashion we have
been overhead big we should have we
should have done it
we have been great I could change right
now if you with a beard
it's alright could you handle the show
outer it's 20 minutes well our people
have made comments that we look similar
so yeah it might be confusing to the
audience your hair is a little flat it
is that that's the main difference here
all right I'm glad we're doing this
because we got a lot to talk about
you've had be on your show and we've
sort of been on each other's maps for
quite some time yeah
so let's start with your history which i
think is really interesting let's talk
marines first before we get into
politics or actually before we even get
into Marines
some little bit about growing up and
where you're from and how that sort of
shape some of your political well I'm
from the Midwest and and so I grew up
there to a conservative household
Christian conservative household and
parents were divorced at 16 and we moved
to Kansas City where it now ended up
living of all places considering the
amount of places I've traveled to and
and I joined the Marine Corps the day
after I graduated from high school so I
went from there and then and then life
continued after that yeah so did you
have any interest in politics in those
early years before you're in the my
carry school you know my father once
asked me he said who's running for
president because he'd read some article
that 80% of the people didn't know who
was running for president and I knew who
it was and I don't know if that was
because my father followed politics or
because I had some sort of interest in
it from the beginning but I don't think
other than how it affected my life I
don't know that I don't know politics
really had a place for me for a lot of
years not at least not until I got out
of the Marines yeah so it was my early
20s before I ever even considered it
yeah so let's talk about the reasons you
go into the Marines was that just sort
of you wanted to figure out what to do
with your life is that something that
you
we wanted to do before that whether that
happen my father used to my father used
to take me camping when I was a kid and
I think if he could have been in the
military he would have been had bad
ankles
and so I always had a kind of gravitated
towards that kind of stuff and when I
was got out of high school one of the
things I knew was I didn't want to go to
school anymore
and I knew I wanted to get out of town
yeah so the quickest way out of town was
into the Marines and so I I joined the
Marine Corps and that was I wasn't sure
I just knew I wanted to travel I knew I
wanted to be somewhere else other than
Kansas yeah and I didn't want to end up
in a school somewhere studying because I
frankly always I was a mediocre student
at best not not necessarily I don't know
if it was because I didn't have any
intelligence it was more I didn't have
to drive and so rather than spend a
bunch of money I didn't have because we
were not a rich family the Marine Corps
seemed like a logical option yeah and
then it did take you all over the world
it did it took me everywhere yeah it
took I started out in an infantry unit
and I did that for a little while until
I realized there's there's really
nothing in an infantry in a year a
bullet sponge it's a cop he sees me I'm
down rinse and repeat charge the hill
charge the hill so they had an
indoctrination for a sniper unit and
anytime you want to get into a
specialized unit they make you in doc
and which is a just a period of time
where they put you through hell to see
if you really want to be there a nice to
trust to test mental and physical
ability mental more than physical and so
I went on this in doc and there were
like 40 people who tried out and we
ended they took four of us and so then I
worked in a sniper team for about four
for about a year before we deployed to
Okinawa and there were two guys ahead of
me and four guys that came with me for
sniper school quota and I knew that it
just wasn't going to happen in my first
year I was going to re-enlist and so I
ended up trying out at the force
reconnaissance team we in docked again
in Okinawa with the force reconnaissance
battalion and I was accepted into that
unit and I spent the remainder of my
time doing that kind of traveling around
Asia and
working in mainly hostage rescue
counterterrorism that kind of thing yeah
why would we need snipers in a place
like okay now what like is this just
part of the sort of broader military
yeah we obviously have bases in Japan
that's right we saw about if the
question is why do we have bases in
Okinawa that's a different question we
can get to that liner shift to the
libertarian stuff in a few minutes but
every unit every unit has has sniper
capabilities in it because you need them
as forward observers they act as both
forward observers and designated
marksmen if they're needed for that so
in each unit there's a in each battalion
there's a group dedicated a platoon
dedicated person IPERS yes
what what's it like right when you show
up for the Marines because that you know
we we have all these ideas about the
military and the Marines the Navy and
all this stuff but it's mostly from
movies I think you know most people
think of these things you say anything
about the military to me I think of the
first half of full-metal-jacket like
that
my holds a lot it's a well I got unlike
that there's there's less swearing now
because there and there's less there's
less physical violence with the with the
with the drill instructors directly you
know hitting or punching or but it's all
it's all there the the idea of the
Marine Corps and the difference between
the Marine Corps and every other branch
of service that I'm aware of is that
most of the other branch of the service
try and take you where you are and build
on that so they're like this is what
I've got let's build on what we've got
the Marine Corps wants to tear you all
the way down and so everything that you
do from the time you get there is about
your racing personal identity and
stripping you of that you're you are
nothing you are a marine and only a
marine and you are now reborn and that
is that is the entire process is
mentally breaking you down and so
everything from when your feet hit the
they've got little yellow footprints
from the time your feet hit that the
very first thing you do is go in and you
put everything you own into a box and
you have that box goes away you get it
back at the end of boot camp but by then
you're already reprogrammed yeah how
long does that programming process take
I assume it's different for everybody I
mean you know the length the duration of
the program is a certain amount of time
but not everybody is going to get there
in the same attic some people never get
there and they they get there they get
kicked out they don't if they can't
conform then that they'll do everything
they can to make it happen but if they
can't they'll just say well you you
non-conforming they'll kick you out and
but it takes the 90 days in psychology
you learn and I learned this through
trading and teaching people takes about
60 to 90 days to break a bad habit and
another 60 to 90 days to reinstall a new
habit so if you're doing it on the quick
immersion you can probably get that done
in 60 to 90 days which is about what
boot camp is now the only months long
for a guy like you that kind of an
independent thinker and you like doing
big your own way and all that was that
extremely difficult or had you not even
about no I was I was drinking the
kool-aid long before I went yeah when I
was ready I was fine with it it's funny
my my ideas about war and about politics
and about what's right and moral have
changed so dramatically over the last
several years as I've seen war war
really changes things not just seeing
war but also seeing I got to see a
different side of war because I was not
only in it but I worked for and and
assisted the diplomatic side of things
so when you're working on that end of it
you get to see what is the State
Department really doing what is the DoD
really doing not the troops on the
ground who are out running patrols or
the generals talking about what's the
overall mission and you get to see a
bigger picture of what's happening and
what I saw was something I didn't like
you didn't like it just because of the
bureaucracy of it or the directions the
things were going you're talking about
Iraq yeah Iraq Afghanistan yeah you can
extend it into Syria and and Egypt and
all those other places but but in terms
the places you've been
yeah Iraq Afghanistan - both so this is
the thing when when you're in the
Marines the idea and what they sell you
on is you are here defending American
liberty you are the force that protects
the freedoms that we hold dear and I
drank that in and I believed it Marines
don't lie cheat or steal these types of
things now that's ridiculous Marines or
some of the you know some terrible
people in many cases you got to do it
again well it's
it takes all time but I drank this idea
that we are that we are here to protect
who to be that line of defense and what
you find out when you actually end up in
war that that's not what it is that it's
a it's a money-making scheme that it's a
lot of people at state and justifying
their jobs and a lot of contractors
making a lot of money off of the process
and doing everything that they can to
ensure that the process continues as
long as humanly possible I'll give you
an example and I'm not exactly sure how
much I can talk about but I'm going to
talk about all of it anyway because they
don't care nobody's like it when nobody
knows each other where this is I'll give
you an example so when I was in Iran in
Iraq war the first patient I had was in
Missoula and I went there because four
guys have been killed in a vehicle uh
vehicle ided two days before so I go up
there to replace one of the four guys
who'd been killed and our job was
protecting diplomats who were part of
the Provincial Reconstruction Team
they're building roads and bridges and a
waterway and drilling wells and things
like that so we were this is the good
old days of Iraq this is right in it
like this is the war it already happened
but now they were trying to real yeah
this is four miles in 2004-2005 and yeah
just to give everybody a framework so
we're but Missoula was one of the most
dangerous places in Iraq at that time
something like 21
IEDs a day we're going off in the city
so we spent a lot of time running from
forward operating bases down to
Parliament so that our diplomats could
talk to their diplomats and everything
is done in cash so you bringing the big
in many cases big amounts of cash back
and forth to pay for these projects well
then these guys would have to go out and
survey the roads that were supposed to
be being built in the progress and the
wells that were being done and I can
remember taking one of these guys out to
erode east of the city that was supposed
to there were sort of laying pavement
onto it and it wasn't even it really
wasn't even started yet they've managed
to kind of flatten the road out but none
of the work had been done and
essentially we were just transferring
money from American taxpayers to this
other group and
to this Araki group and the question was
well how do we get this money spent yeah
we've got this money we gotta get it
spent on something and and this is just
it was a perpetual process of us taking
money from people who rightfully earned
it and then giving it to a country uh so
that they could essentially squander it
and I started to realize at that point
look what are we doing here what is this
really about if not about in protecting
American liberty it's not even about
providing democracy to the Iraqi people
it's it's about something else and it
really put a distaste in my mouth for
and really showed the difference between
what I was what I believed I was doing
and what I was really doing yeah do you
think two things could be true at the
same time that had democracy worked
there because there was that year where
they had free elections when we were
still there and things were actually
turning around I've talked about this
with a bunch of different guests could
both of those things have worked at the
same time that whatever our machine is
whatever the money-making machine and
the military thing but at the same time
we could have brought true freedom which
obviously hasn't worked now I think if
you're quite possibly so here's the one
caveat I would make is that P I assumed
as an American that everyone wanted
Liberty that this was just an innate
desire that we have as mankind men and
women that we have a desire to be free
my what I found in the Middle East is
that wasn't the case I can remember
sitting with an interpreter or a man who
later moved here to America to protect
himself and his family and he he did
more as an Iraqi to protect us while we
were there than probably anybody else we
got more good Intel from him he put his
life on the line every day to help us
accomplish our mission in Iraq and I was
sitting against a Humvee while we were
outside Parliament one day and he said
to me that these people need a dictator
they need someone to tell them what to
do and I was very angry at the time that
he would say that what are we here
fighting for what do you believe does
you claim to be for our mission but you
don't you don't claim to support
democracy and more importantly Liberty
and the fact is there's a huge
difference between a democratic between
democracy and liberty
democracy is just hey we would we get to
decide on what kind of tyrant we want
and liberty is a principle that says I
have a right to be freed I believe in
self ownership and there's a spreading
Liberty or inscription to me spreading
democracy to a group that doesn't
believe fundamentally in Liberty will
always end in some sort of tyranny yeah
do you think it's possible that it's not
that they don't believe in Liberty but
they haven't been afforded the
opportunities in terms of education and
a worldliness that unfortunately we in
the West seem to take for granted now
more than ever so if they had just
gotten that the education first then
then the next step of oh this is why
Liberty is important this is why I want
it and now here's how I want to build a
democracy like is that how we have to
start but I think it's it's very
interesting that you bring that up
because I think that's one of the
reasons we're seeing our liberties slip
away here in America is because there's
been a lack of education you have to
teach someone why it works in order for
them to understand what you're doing
here on this show and the success that
you've had in trying to try to get it
principles and ideas and promote those
is what is what's going to cause the
critical change in America if we're
going to see one and I think that one of
the big problems in the Middle East is
that they've never known what it is so
they can't understand it and so that
even if we built the proper institutions
for them that the underpinning of really
understanding the philosophical stuff
wouldn't be strong enough to keep that I
don't know and the question that I
always ask is why is it is it why is it
our responsibility to do it and I would
say if you believe in those types of
things well then you have a right in a
responsibility if not the obligation to
try and to give what you have and to try
and convince as many other people as
possible to do the same thing yeah but
you don't have the right to take from
somebody else our government has no
business being over there building
countries and spreading democracy
because as we've seen in Iraq and Syria
and Afghanistan we don't know when we're
doing we only make the problem worse
yeah the Afghanistan one which I
probably should be spending more time
talking about not only me but everybody
should is now I think our longest war
or every day of Obama's presidency was
at war with Afghanistan it continues now
I don't think anyone has a clue at least
publicly as to what we're actually doing
there they don't were not there not
right later
they were not trying to make them a
democracy right with the idea was we
were trying to disrupt al Qaeda that
seems sort of archaic and almost
irrelevant at this point I mean we're
just doing this endless thing that can
ever end no you're right and there's no
clear there's no clear idea of why we're
there what are we fighting to achieve
we're essentially we've created an
outpost there and we will be there and
forever if that's what the government
decides it wants to do because the same
thing that you saw in Iraq after the
surge when we pull back is the same
thing that will happen in Afghanistan
you will create a vacuum and that vacuum
will be filled by the most root most
ruthless people that are in that area at
that time
yeah and it's a it really is sad but
it's just that this is not the way that
you fight wars unfortunately we have
this idea in America that we need to
fight when it the winning of hearts and
minds is important this is where I will
deviate from many of the of the folks on
the libertarian side of things is that I
am I'm not a pacifist I think that we
should stay away stay out of war the war
is a violent and an evil thing and that
we should stay out at all cost but when
it's time to fight we're ruthless I mean
we drive your women and children out
into the cold dark night and we hang
your men from the rafters we do whatever
we have to do to win as quickly as
possible to crush them everything their
their desire and their ability to resist
this is how you win wars historically
that's how it's been done it's only
until roughly Vietnam era that we
decided that what we really needed to do
was win the hearts and minds of the
people and what that has led to is one
failure after another in American
military policy yeah so you're you're
into the Powell doctrine right I mean
that's basically what you described
there that you just win it as quickly as
possible
crush him do what you have to do and
then before that you judge a Ronald doc
well I think that's what that's what
people say isn't our doctrine but
ironically he had a lot to do with the
Iraq war adviser mean
what we did there well and see I would I
pal I think disagreed with the Iraq war
as well if you break it you buy it if I
remember right right was also telling us
about uranium rod yes you're right never
saw anything at all you're right about
that yeah I am knowing what I what I
know now what I understand about foreign
policy and about the the military I
would have never advocated for going
into that war and I wouldn't advocate
doing it again because American Liberty
isn't threatened we we have a response I
think America has a responsibility to
have a defensive military something to
protect our liberties but we don't have
the right to go and fight a war because
of American interest and that's what you
hear politicians constantly talk about
is well we've got American interests
over there well the interesting thing is
is that America will always find an
interest where it wants to exert its
power now every government will so there
has to be a higher standard than
government need in order for us to
whether you're talking about the Fourth
Amendment right to privacy or
unreasonable search and seizure or
whether you're talking about going to
war you know what do you make of slow
creep of all of this but now we end up
in wars that aren't even declared wars
yeah you know where we have drones in
Pakistan right now we're not at war with
Pakistan but I'm pretty sure if Pakistan
had a drone flying over LA people would
consider that an act of war you know we
had major ships outside of Syria we have
military actions obviously happening in
Syria but we're not at war with Syria
what do you think Justin but what does
that say about the state of the way our
government is supposed to work that you
know used to be that Congress would
authorize war the president would sign
it and then we go to war and now we've
lost that well I think it's criminal is
what I think it is I think the
government the Congress has delegated
its authority away it doesn't have the
constitutional ability to do that it a
Congress are a bunch of cowards is what
they are now is that they they come in
and they they claim that what you can
take I don't care what you want to talk
about we can stay on foreign policy
because that's kind of what we're
talking about but what they decided to
do was we don't want to have to declare
war and be on the record for declaring
war so what we'll do is we'll authorize
the President to do whatever he thinks
is right and then we can complain about
it or say that we supported it from the
beginning right
depending on how it all turns out and
there's a reason that which is the
biggest dereliction of duty they cope I
absolutely it is not just that they're
not doing something they're actually
feeding power that they are supposed to
have four checks and balances to another
branch of though and I don't think
that's when they founded the the the
country and written wrote the
Constitution I don't think that's
something they ever planned on or
anticipated is that people who had power
would relinquish it but their power is
derived from the ability to be reelected
and so it's like the Republicans who
promised us for eight years that they
were going to fix the Obamacare problems
that we saw and now we find out that
what we're going to get is probably
something worse it's probably going to
be worse for the people who are paying
taxes and worse for the worse for the
people receiving benefits yeah they are
absolutely some of the most spineless
cowardly people on the planet I have if
it goes Congress lawyers which most of
them are mess our salesmen watch
traitors yeah and I like that you're not
making a distinction here between
political party no I was they both do it
right when the Republicans were
controlling the house and Obama's
president they didn't want to do
anything he didn't want to work with
them nobody did anything and now people
don't you know the Democrats don't want
to work with Trump is it it's the same
old thing yeah I think it's a one of the
one things I like about your show is
that it's not there's not a political
party attached to it I think they're
both horrible we have oh yeah I've
passed about that I'm trying to agree a
clearly and see that's the difference is
that when you approach it from a
principled position you notice you start
to recognize that hey my team sucks I'm
fond of saying if you're a Republican
your party sucks if you're a Democrat
your party sucks if you have a party
that your party sucks yeah you know
they're just they're not any good and
one of the problems that we have in
America is that they've created two
teams we have the Capulets and the
Montagues and you you associate yourself
with one of those two teams you you wear
their colors and then you sort of view
your job as defending and making excuses
for your side and pointing out well they
do though the other side does the same
thing and back and forth this is what
guys like Rush Limbaugh Sean Hannity all
these even commentators on the right
have done free
years rightly they've established a a
team and in their job every day is to go
out and defend the team how to work out
for the kids in there with the
capitalism money yeah not well it did
not work out well if I remember
correctly and it won't work out well for
us either we're away from principle and
now we're bickering and fighting over
things that frankly don't matter yeah
and that's why I'm really trying to keep
this about some principles lay out some
terms and some definitions and things
like that and then of what the funny
thing is that if you do that kind of
thing then then people hate you from
every time because they can't even
understand wait a minute you're not
jumping to defend this when you're not
jumping to defend that but well that you
say what what is it for you like when
you when you try and identify this is
what I believe what is it Liberty but
what is that with freedom your right to
live your life as you see fit ok period
Liz and let live now that doesn't mean
we can't have a government and this is
I'm glad you asked that because now we
can shift into some of your libertarian
beliefs I believe in human liberty that
it is that through my mind I will figure
out what is the best life to live for
myself and through that I will live the
best life that probably will be for my
neighbors and I won't pollute my local
River just because I can and I will try
to find work that will be rewarding to
me and then I can use my money to hire
other people to do things and all of
those things about about Liberty which I
now believe is simply the most
importantly so but it's as much a
personal philosophy of how you live your
life as much as it is a political
philosophy yeah I think it's it's the
former first yeah I think that's more
important we start here you start in
your mind and then you go out from there
I don't at the other way would be well I
guess the other way is collectivism
right the other way is getting the other
in the other screen would be
collectivism yeah we're one person or a
group of people decide what everybody
else is going to do right so the funny
thing about the word Liberty is it's
been so associated with either
libertarianism or conservatism or things
that are thought of as on the right
where it very much is a liberal
principle yes to live and let live is
liberal it is not progressive and it's
not less than I've been trying to make
some point over the last two years
my biggest doing an okay job of it but
when did that idea that concept of
Liberty really hit you so that I get
through with all within this it was
within being at war and it wasn't it was
actually when I was there I was I was
trading currencies and so on studying
markets and I'm studying uh currencies
has a lot to do with what's happening
with central bank's and the political
decisions that governments make those
affect currency prices as much as
anything else and so I'm in a deep
studying trying to understand all right
when the central bank raises rates what
happens to the currency why does it do
that when when a government decides that
it's going to raise taxes or something
like that what is the effect on currency
markets because I wanted to make money
at it and I ended up reading a book by
Ron Paul called a manifesto the
revolution a manifesto and I thought Ron
Paul was this crazy old man because when
I saw him on TV I was just like all
right that guy says some cool things but
he's really a kook yeah and I read his
book and it was one of the most coherent
ideas about Liberty that I'd ever read
it basically someone had gotten into my
head had laid out everything that I was
thinking but couldn't articulate and put
it into a book it was in that book and I
I just I drank it in I said this is
what's wrong with the war this is what's
wrong with what's happening in our
government and and I was I saw a
solution and so naturally I just
continued my education and that takes
you I got all kinds of crazy routes to
very extreme ideas and and that's that's
really where that came from was
realizing that I was being lied to that
we were hurting hundreds of thousands
not millions of people and then our
government was not there to help that
they didn't have anything to offer that
they didn't care about me or you or
anyone else that they had very different
motives and once that happened it was a
life-changing experience
[Music]
you